things are heating up between jennifer
lopez and ben affleck
now a source tells e.t their friends
wouldn't be surprised if they moved in
together
and ultimately end up together i'm
thrilled do you know me i was super
happy
quote they're spending all of their free
time together and making each other a
priority
j-lo falls hard and has certainly done
the same with ben again this time around
the two famously known as benifer
recently rekindled their romance
17 years after their split in 2004. the
source adds quote
ben is a guy's guy and does his own
thing which
jlo loves it's great he has his
own life and is famous in a different
way than she is and is not trying to
compete with her by any means
they just support and love each other
the two first started dating back in
2002
while starring in their first movie
together julie
i'm sorry do we know each other not yet
they
quickly got engaged but by 2003 they
called off their wedding just
days before their planned september
ceremony and they officially split
in january 2004. it was my first like
adult heartbreak we were about to get
married
it didn't work out and it was just a bad
heartbreak
like you know just one of those breakups
that really you know
it was like a tough one for me for
whatever reason
for many reasons but they reconnected
earlier this year
after the triple threat called it quits
with her fiance alex rodriguez
now e.t source says when ben reached out
to her she was
really excited at the possibility of
them rekindling their relationship
quote j-lo has always had a love for ben
back in the day ben
broke up with jlo because he was
overwhelmed by the constant media
attention and fame that the relationship
brought
but now they are in an amazing place and
have really learned what works for them
as a couple and if all that wasn't cute
enough
fans recently noticed that jlo has been
liking pics of her man
on benifer fan accounts i do love that
e.t
source also notes that their
relationship is not a big deal to either
sets of kids
adding that their children aren't super
sensitive to the situation
of course jennifer is mom to 13 year old
twins emmy and max
whom she shares with her ex-husband mark
anthony while ben
shares fifteen-year-old violet old
seraphina and nine-year-old samuel with
his ex-wife jennifer garner
as for how their exes feel about the
whole thing she's
really funny and amazing and she's just
magical
a source previously told et that a-rod
quote
regrets some of his actions and feels
like he messed things up with jen
but he's doing his best to move on
meanwhile a different source told
et that jennifer garner is happy for her
ex
finding love with jlo